It turns out this actually another method to charge by induction.
This method, just like the first method, also uses two spheres
but here, one of those spheres is actually the earth.
Let's say you have your conducting sphere and it's attached to the ground by a conducting rod.
Let's also add a bunch of wires that extend into the ground
and then let's hold a positive charge over our conducting sphere.
What's going to happen is that we're going to actually draw electrons from the earth.
If we then detached this sphere, we can even remove the positive charge
and now here we have it, a negatively charged sphere.
And this negative charges somehow came from the ground.
Now, of course, this must mean that throughout the earth,
there must be a few extra positive charges lingering around.
They've lost their electrons.
It seems like if we were to do this experiment over and over and over,
well, eventually we'd have a positively charged earth and that might be a problem.
It turns out that this is a non-issue and I want you to tell me
why you think this works and why it's a non-issue?
Maybe you think the earth is somehow able to create electrons
create this negative charges, so that actually there's no residual positive charge leftover.
Maybe it has something to do with the fact that the earth is huge.
Maybe that has something to do with the reason why this never becomes a problem
where we actually wind up charging the earth with some noticeable amount.
Or maybe you think the earth is an insulator, something in which charges cannot move
and that this somehow saves us and allows this whole process to work.
Check what you think is the best answer.